what you see here is my semesters worth
of work of myself defined exploration
the semester I just kind of wanted to
look at how I could make furniture
that's or a bit more interactive the
surface is continuously changing
especially on this one is sort of left
in a different orientation every time
someone sits on it and kind of moves
around or whatever and what a way you
can kind of changes the pattern slightly
so i ended up decided to do a bench for
an indoor space could be a museum art
gallery anything of this sort my piece
looks at taking the seats angling them
towards each other to encourage
conversations between people who might
not have had one otherwise this class is
one of the few opportunities that we
have to not just design things would
make the things that we have been
designing this house has been really
great to get that experience of building
it and having a tangible object at the
end so originally I started out by
looking at how I might be able to create
a piece of furniture that would attach
to the human body and so that could
extend out and he could walk
children become part of you but it was a
little bit too conceptual and i was
looking at how might be able to take
that idea of furniture being parasitic
in that way and bring it to something
that could be more practical as they
said when you have to deal with all
those constraints you know the trick is
to go on to your initial design tent 114
involves base Toews austrians from you
know from making a really it's amazing
how original the ideas continued to be